toute histoire invite à un voyage il et
initiatique où existe la rencontre avec
une ligne la découverte nos foisonnement
de culture de métissage de croisement de
rencontre des changes
neil houleux
la partie justement par sa diversité et
par ses différents apports est riche par
rapport à d'autres espaces
français ou de métropole j'ai passé
presque toute ma carrière
professionnelle ici j'ai mes enfants ici
mon mari martiniquais donc j'estime
avoir la légitimité pour parler de cette
identité culturelle hélas sur ses terres
volcaniques la nature est capricieuse la
végétation luxuriante peut à tout moment
laissé place à la fois des menaces
climatiques qui sont les responsables
les acteurs les spectateurs d'une
surconsommation débridée
[Musique]
chronique d'une mort annoncée d'une
destruction minutes et la pression monte
la cocotte n'a plus de soupape la
destruction fait partie de l'ensemble
des germes et donc comment on arrive à
survivre à cette pensée même si elle
s'appuie autant sur la science que sur
la relation que c'est que
[Musique]
il se construire une philosophie coeur
meurtri d'un espace en déséquilibre
l'heure est à la réflexion à
l'introspection
comment remettre du ko lorsque l'eau
mais l'archipel ne font qu'un
heureusement il demeure un espoir celui
de pouvoir reconstruire avec des bouts
de ficelle avec de revenir de bois avec
des moufles guérir nos âmes
[Musique]
ben moi
césaire lumière qui nous invite à une
certaine décroissance lemaitre que ça
entre 10 mai quand une certaine sagesse
nous invite à ne pas se croire obligé
d'aller trouver des matériaux
sophistiqués à dix mille kilomètres
thérapie des mots pour guérir des maux
les objets recyclés pour exprimer pour
s'exprimer à dien d'une expo au cours de
laquelle l'artiste amateur et plasticien
confirmé dépeignent dans les antres de
l'atrium leurs tribulations archipélique